bonjour bernard perez
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin sur arte france pour parler
d'un autre problème qui concerne la
pêche en ce moment il ya vos collègues
qui luttent pour avoir davantage de
licence dans la manche vous votre
problème c'est la crainte que les quotas
de pêche baisse il ya une réunion avec
les ministres à bruxelles les 12 et 13
décembre
quel est votre crainte vous avez déjà
entamé des actions 1
oui alors notre crainte elle est simple
et déjà je tiens à souligner que nous
sommes un total soutien pour le break
site et nous plus particulièrement pour
la méditerranée c'est une diminution du
quota des jours de mer voilà et
les négociations commencent dimanche à
bruxelles et pour manifester et pour
soutenir le gouvernement français la
ministre par rapport à ces négociations
nous faisons une mobilisation sur tous
les ports de méditerranée
ce samedi matin voilà pour manifester
sur le grau du roi cet habitat et pour
la nouvelle c'est à dire quoi elle s'est
bloqué les ports
oui on va on va bloquer les ports et à
faire un talent voilà que qu'il ya une
dizaine de jours depuis des années le
pêcheur peut être
veut une pêche durable et responsable
des sûr mais pas à n'importe quel prix
et aujourd'hui
le seuil de rentabilité de nos armes aux
mains et de 209 jours de mer puisqu'il
ya eu une augmentation du prix du gasoil
et est aujourd'hui nous sommes limités
pour l'année 2000 21 à 183 jours alors
que notre seuil de rentabilité
aujourd'hui et à 200
ce sommet sur les quotas se tient chez
un cadet mais chaque année il n'y a pas
cette inquiétude que vous avez
aujourd'hui alors pour quelle raison le
ce côté jours de mer pourrait baisser
mais chaque année il est révolue et il
est discuté en conseil des ministres
chaque année à la même période et je
regardais les articles de l'année
dernière on arrivait à tenir et
justement c'est ce que je vous explique
c'est que nous avons un seuil de
rentabilité aujourd'hui on est largement
en dessous du seuil de rentabilité
etc ca a vécu une boule au ventre que je
vous le dis haut rang on est à demander
des plans de sortie de flotte c'est
inadmissible
en tant que représentant d'une
profession je ne veux pas me résigner à
demander un plan de sortie de flotte ici
ce qu'on va demander pour sauver la
profession ça fait partie des choses
qu'on demande c'est une catastrophe
qu'est ce que vous êtes et un plan de
sortie de flotte
mais c'est à dire que les arguments qui
ne peuvent plus payer et qui ne peut qu
ils ne sont plus rentables vont me
demander un plan de casse voilà c'est à
dire qu'on casse les bateaux pour qu'ils
n'aillent plus en mer
mais bien sûr on va on va casser des
bateaux si les négociations ça a été
annoncé par la ministre en scop il ya
une dizaine de jours et c'est vers sakho
sourd et ses salles entre demain parce
que c'est notre seule sortie de secours
mais voilà pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un
que les libyens vivant dans ce domaine
je vous en nous demandant surtout
surtout
un statu quo par rapport à la diminution
des jours de mer parce que sinon c'est
plus possible vers des zones en
permanence on a un effort de pêche qui
nous est demandé une diminution de
l'effort de pêche on perd des zones où
on prêt servent nos géniteurs où on
ferme pendant huit mois de l'année 90 à
100 mètres à des
[Musique]
désobéisseurs cargaison est ce qu on
restreint justement ce nombre de jours
de pêche pour bien comprendre
mais pas parce qu'il ya il ya un état
dit stop qui est fait sur le merlin et
sur le rouge est alors que nous pêchons
à l'heure actuelle quatre entre 50 et 80
espèces et il est fait des études que
sur deux espèces
merci merci beaucoup bernard perez de
nous avoir répondu ce matin en direct
sur arte france